[音楽]
皆さんこんにちははじめまして
古林観音です
突然ですが今日は
未来は変えられるけど
過去は変えられないいやそうじゃなくて
未来が変われば
過去も変わるそれを伝えにここにやってき
ました
さて
2019年3月私が小学校6年生の時の
ことです
小学校の卒業式の時に人生で初めてみんな
の前で
泣きました
侍かって言われるかもしれないんですけど
母の前でしか
泣かないって物心をついた時からずっと
キムチだから自分でもその
止まらない涙に
びっくりしました
でもその
抑えきれない涙の背景には
成功と失敗人の目を気にするカッコつけな
性格の自分
答えのわからない数々の問い生きることへ
の不安誰かへの嫉妬心いろんなことが
混ざり合っていたと思います
今日はそれでもあなたにはあなたの居場所
がある
正直明日私がいなくても世界は回ります
でも自分を必要としてくれる人が
必ずいるその人たちのために生きてほしい
ということそして私の一番の目標である
いつか誰かの役に立つ人になりたいそんな
お話をしたいです
ところで他の動物にはなくて人間だけが
持っている能力なんだと思いますか
それは
原因と結果を戦場として
結ぶことができることだと思います
そう言ってしまうとなるほどそうなのかと
思う人が半分
うーんそうなのかなと思う人が半分だと
思います
けれどこう考えてほしい
生き物があることをする時ミラーを予想し
て結果を予測しながら行動できる生き物は
きっと人間だけだと
つまり予想予測できるのは人間だけだと
思います
そこで自由なのは
想像力です
巷でよく耳にするsdgsだってそうです
まだ来ていない未来まだ起きていないこと
に対する責任をどうやって取るのでしょう
次にこう考えてほしい
未来から見た現在という名の過去だったら
私たちは
過去を変えられるんだとつまり
未来という視点から
想像力を使って現在を見たら
過去を変えられるということです
その視点というのは
未来という名の現在という視点です
私はまだ16年しか生きていませんでも
その中でいろんな人と出会って
成功や
失敗を経験してきました
辛い時に思うのはあの頃に戻りたい
踊れるはずがないし大人から前を向けと
言われるけれど
過去を振り返ってしまうのが人間という
生き物なのかもしれません
でも逆に
成功した時私たちはまた同じように過去を
振り返りを振り返るはずです今度は
成功体験よりあの時のしんどい思いや
挫折を思い出すのではないでしょうか
その
失敗談というのはきっとしんどかったら
しんどかった分だけすごく濃いもので自分
にとって
価値のあるものだと思います
しんどい経験もそれは生きている限り
未来のための一歩になる
私にとってそれはなくてはならない過去
だったそう言えると思います
人間は他の動物の遺伝子の増殖に加えて
自分の分身をもう一つ別の形で他者や次
世代に移すことができます
それは心です
言い換えればソフトウェアです
コミュニケーションを通して他者にコピー
されるのです
自分の中で
刻々と変化し他者へと転送され今度はその
意識でその人のアイデンティティの一部と
して増殖していくソフトウェアです
このソフトウェアですが他社に伝えられた
時私たちはそれを
承諾しないといけません
相手の
害にならずためになるというのが
条件なのです
つまり相手への思いやりや愛が大事だと
いうことを言いたいです
これは
普段利用しているSNSでも言えること
です
SNSでは
毎日のように
誹謗中傷で
悩まれている人がたくさんいます
これを
解決するためにはSNSをなくせばいいの
でしょうかそれが正しいとは思いません
私はSNSをある種の
居場所としての可能性を信じたいです
みんな自分の居場所があるから生きて
いけると思います
家も学校も
図書館も
SNSもそのうちの一つなんじゃないかな
と考えます
そこで大事なのは心というソフトウェア
です
ここで少し
走ってどんな人間か同じさせてください
人前でしゃべるのが好きだしなんかしょう
もないことでもツボっちゃって笑っちゃう
みたいなでもこの前母が私のこと天真爛漫
なインキャて言ってくれてこの表現は自分
にピッタリだと思ってすごく嬉しかった
です
そんな私の生き方は結構変わってます
私の母はすごく教育熱心で
幼稚園の時は
隣町のモンテッソーレ教育の私立の幼稚園
に通って本当に自由に過ごしてきました
そして受験を通して国立の小学校公立の中
学校そして今は私立の女子校に通ってい
ます
そんな私は
毎回入学した時にいつも思うんです
自分の価値観や生き方が正しいかどうか
またわからなくなったと
私が通っていた国立の小学校は教科書を
使わない授業が大半で自分を主張すること
がいいとされる本当に自由な学校だったと
思います
でも公立の中学校に通って勉強が得意な子
苦手な子
裕福な家庭環境の子そうでない子社会の
縮図のような環境で私って周りから浮いて
いないかなとまず心配になりました
国立との大きな違いは自分小学校の時には
何かを競ったことはなかったけれど
常に何かしら人と競い合うことを学んだ
ことです
世の中やっぱり
常に競争社会やと思い知らされた瞬間でも
ありました
そして今は
ジェンダーフリーと言われている中で女子
校が存在することに驚きがあり最初は
戸惑うところも多くて自分に合わないかな
と思ったりしてしんどいことも正直あり
ました
でも割り切って自分の描いてきた理想の
学校生活ではないけれど女の子しかいない
生活だからできることもたくさんあって今
はやっと楽しめるようになりました
どれもいいんだけどどれも間違っていない
んだけど新しい
環境に行くと今まで正しいと思ってきた
ことが
移転されているように感じます
それはどの学校も目指している目標が違う
から学校に行きたくなくなったり今の自分
に自信がなくなってしまいます
また世の中のいい子と言われる子供は
素直で勉強ができる子または
素直だが勉強はできないと言われる
いわゆる愛されキャラの子そういう子は
学校で生活しやすいです
でも私が思ういい子というのは自分のこと
が好きであることそして
友達や
仲間のことが好きであることこの2つが
揃っていい子と呼ぶんじゃないのかなと
思います
私の
友達と中には
環境が原因で学校に行けなくなった友達も
います誰も何も間違っていないのに私は
その当時自分のことに必死でその苦しい
思いをしている友達に何もできませんでし
たそこが今
振り返ると一番
悔しいことですもし私が何かできていたら
今が変わっていたかもしれないと本気で
思うからです
自分で言うのはちょっと照れくさいけど
小さい頃は何でもうまくいったんです
まさか小学校受験に受かると思ってい
なかったのに国立小学校に受かって両親を
驚かせました
3歳の時からずっとバレエを習っていて
すごい」って言われることもありました
バレリーナになることを夢見て
頑張る日常が続いた時周りに大人から褒め
られることがうれしくてそれが生きがいに
なりました
週7日バレー教室まで1時間かかり夜家に
帰ってくると日付が変わりそうになる日々
を過ごしてきました
しかし小学校6年生の時に出場したバレエ
の世界大会でバレエでは生きていけない
ことを確信しました
そして
ちょうどそのコンクールの後の中学の内部
入試も
緊張でうまくいきませんでした
一言で言うと人生の中で一番の絶望だっ
た今まで周りの目しか気にしていなくて誰
かにすごいと言われることが良いことだと
思ってきたから
余計ショックでした
結局自分はカッコつけでかっこのスキル
ラインままになってしまったと思いました
その時自分はバレエも勉強も失ってしまっ
て私の人生はもう終わったと本気で思い
ました
夢を叶えられるのはほんの数パーセントの
天才だと思うようになりました
生まれ持った
骨格や
才能がなければどんだけ頑張っても無理な
んだと自分に言い聞かせるようになりまし
た
自分はもう大人として生きていかなければ
ならない現実を受け入れなければならない
私の
毎日は
曇り空へと変わりました
小学校
低学年の時がピークだったなぁ自分が思う
理想像ってこんなはずじゃなかったあの
美しいバレリーナになるんじゃなかったっ
け
小さい頃
理想が高いと高い分だけ
余計しんどくなります
あの時もっと頑張れば良かった私がその時
頭に浮かんだのはハロー絶望これが現実な
んだと思いました
私の中学生活は小学校の時まともに勉強し
ていなかったから
恥ずかしながら中2の夏に勝利の計算
ドリルから始めなんとか中3レベルには
行ったものの中3のとき中3レベルには
行ったものの
ぶっ飛んだ第一志望には受かりませんでし
た
またまた次こそはとか言っときながら
失敗したんです
そして高校では分かっていたけれど女子校
で女の子しかいない環境に結構
びっくりしてまた失敗したって思ってそこ
でとにかくやけくそになりました
学校で
海外支援のボランティアの募集があって
なぜか私は
過去の自分の
失敗例を綴った論文を
担任の先生に送ったんです
書きなぐった論文あんな文章を誰が読むね
んって思ったけどある先生がすごいと褒め
てくださってすごく
嬉しかったですたまにだけど人生生きてい
たら
波に乗るもんですだけクソ精神でペットに
受かって今日ここに立っています正直結構
びっくりしました
あの時勉強してけばよかったとかバレエを
あんだけ必死にやったけど
結局うまくいかなかったからもっと早く
辞めとけばよかったかなとか
公立中学校が最初全然なれなくてつらかっ
たからそもそも国立小学校を受験しなけれ
ばよかったかなとか思うこともたくさん
ありました
でも
母と二人三脚で頑張ってきたバレ
なんやかんやで乗り越えてきた事件朝
泣いて学校に行けない時今日休みって連絡
してきてくれた友達がいるから今こうやっ
てこの舞台に立てているここでくじけて
いる場合じゃないこの経験があって今が
あるそう強く思います
中学2年生の時小学校の友達が自ら命を
絶ちました
中学受験の時たまたま横に座っていた友達
めっちゃ頭良くて運動もできて
器用で本が大好きで
素敵な友達でした
中学も受験に受かってすごく羨ましかった
自分のなりたかった人でしただからなんで
めっちゃ幸せやなのになんでなショックで
頭が真っ白になると同時に不思議で
仕方がありませんでした
人にはやっぱり
悩みがあるその理由を彼女から聞くことは
できなかった今でも誰もわからないでも
その時気づいて声をかけてあげればよかっ
たって後悔の気持ちしか残りません
私も誰も私の気持ちなんかわからんって
思って中学生活を送ってきましたでも中3
の時大好きな担任の先生との出会いがあり
ました
私がつらかった時に先生に自分の思いを
泣きじゃくって伝えた経験があります
その当時内申点を取ることにとにかく必死
だったんですでもその時先生になんか私の
気持ちなんかわかるわけないとか言って
やんなくしたんです
やんなきゃしてとにかくめっちゃ暴れまし
た
私はあのことは取り消せるなら取り消した
いってまあでもずっと思ってます
中学に入学してから別に公立通訳でも悪く
ないだろう」ってずっと自分に言い聞かせ
てきました
そうやって現実を受け止めてきたんだと
思います
けれど本当は小学校からそのまま
エスカレート式で国立に行きたかったから
もしそのままだったらこんな辛い思いはせ
ずに済んだはずだそう思ってました
でも実際はそんなこと全くなくてこの中
学校に行って心を許せる先生や友達と
出会えてよかったと本気で思います
自分の思いを誰かに伝えることがどんだけ
大事なことかわかった瞬間でした
自分の本音で喋れる人がそばにいること
それが一番大切なことだと思います
そこで
私の思いを聞いてくれた先生を私の第三の
居場所サードプレイスと呼びたいです
自分の心を開ける場所や人がいたら生きて
いけるそしてその辛い瞬間を乗り越えれば
あとは時間が解決してくれるんじゃないか
なと思います
日本の教育は自分に合わない
友達との交流とか先生とか勉強することが
辛いってなるといやいや強くなれよとか
言ってしまう大人たちがいます
そんなこと言われなくてもわかってます
分かってもらえないことがつらいです
逆に
貧困な国ではお金がないだからその国の
子供にとっては学校に行けるだけで幸せ
です
学校に普通に通える日本の子供ですがこれ
はこれですごく深刻な課題だと思います
先ほどからサードプレイスのお話をしてい
ますが私は今戻ってこられる場所として
NPO法人お寺おやつクラブという団体で
居場所づくりのボランティアに参加してい
ます
ここは家でも学校でもない自分のために
ある
居場所の空間です
あなたの居場所はどこかに必ずあります
これを伝えるためにここにいます
生きていることがしんどいとかたまに思う
けど
大好きな歌手のライブに行った時好きな人
と目が合った時何気ない会話をするとき
私たちは生きててよかったと思うはずです
私はいろんなことがあったけど今前を向い
て
必死で生きようって決めてます
これまでの
失敗全てが今の自分につながってる
今日は人生の中で頂点だ
もしかしたらあの時の方が今よりうまく
できていたかもしれない
それでもいろんな過去を含めて今日がある
から今たとえしんどくても
辛くても今すぐ立ち上がれなくても
自分の将来を信じて生きてください
SNSの中でも
夢中になれることでも
これからいろんな人に出会って
失敗してまた失敗したって
立ち止まることもあるけど
未来の居場所は
必ずあります
でも私のソフトウェアの中には
亡くなった友達がずっと生きて
ますこれが
永遠の命だと思います
最後に
中1の時から
陸上部に入りハードルを専門に頑張ってい
ます
ハードルの面白いところは次第でスタート
ライン買った時自分のレーンのみハードル
がまっすぐに見えることですその他の霊園
のハードルは曲がって見えます
人生も同じです自分の
秘めた道しかまっすぐに置かれていません
だから自分で決めておいた目の前の
ハードルを一つ一つ超えることだけよ考え
て生きていけばいいのだと思います
前に進めば道ができますでも後ろの道は
なくてはならない私の過去ですでもその
過去は
未来が変われば
過去も変わるそれを覚えて帰ってください
今日は私のために貴重な時間を使って話を
聞いてくださって本当にありがとうござい
ました以上
栗林かんなでした
[拍手]